[Musique]
monument historique site classé datant
d'une époque où la France ne comptait
pas 30 millions d'habitants
aujourd'hui c'est l'entlacement on le
retrouve partout pourquoi une des causes
principales tient au manque de maisons
de retraite
[Musique]
voici de retour à Paris et je viens vous
annoncer de m'attendre lundi prochain 10
avril entre midi et moins le quart et
midi le lundi donc en attendant je vous
embrasse de tout cœur mademoiselle de
Garfield
tous les trois quatre mois vous savez ah
bon oui c'est agréable
les nouvelles sont bonnes
sont bonnes
c'est une invitation c'est bien vous
changer merci
[Musique]
le déclin du jour
de Germaine Beaumont
[Musique]
parfait très bien
excusez-moi de vous déranger madame on
vous dérange parce qu'on voit que vous
lisez et vous lisez beaucoup oui
beaucoup qu'est-ce que vous lisez là
vous aimez ça vous allez beaucoup au
cinéma il y a beaucoup au cinéma
24 ans
[Musique]
et vous êtes ici depuis longtemps
j'étais à Laurent tout de suite alors
[Musique]
c'était dans une chambre aussi à
vinaigre pendant 15 ans on était
tranquille et on a déménagé on a fait
des travaux
on avait un rideau devant la porte parce
que c'est des anciennes cellules dans le
temps mais alors on a vu nos petites
affaires à nous quoi je crois que vous
êtes né à Vienne non c'est monsieurve
générale qui me l'a dit oui mais vous
savez je ne suis pas autrichienne je
suis née à Vienne prépare en français et
aussi français que vous dans mes papiers
c'est pour ça que quand on veut me
mettre en rage et puis me faire faire
une colère à tout casser Nathalie à
l'Autrichienne si je peux vous demander
quel âge vous avez madame oui
et vous êtes content d'être ici ça va à
peu près
[Musique]
les pommes de terre sont pas toujours
très bonnes il y a longtemps que vous
êtes ici
quand même
et vous les connaissez chacune vous
pouvez dire que vous les connaissez
chacun
je connais leurs habitudes leurs
penchant c'est tout cela j'écoute leurs
petites histoires
elles sont exigeantes certaines
d'autre part d'autres sont très gentils
d'autres difficiles
c'est tout un monde et vous-même vous ne
trouvez vous ne craignez pas que ça
n'est une influence sur vous-même est-ce
que ça ne finit pas par vous rendre un
peu triste un peu mélancolie que vous
n'avez pas envie de changer maintenant
non je suis habitué à elle et vraiment
je ne suis adapté
quand je les quitterai ça me fera un
certain petit choc ça vous fera chaud
oui oui les vieillards au fond il faut
le comprendre
je vais vous poser une question madame
qui peut-être un peu cruelle mais je
crois qu'il faut la poser quand même
qu'est-ce que ça coûte une vieille femme
comme ça qui est sur son lit et qui ne
bouge plus et qui peut rester comme ça
10 ans 15 ans 20 ans nous en avons vu là
qui sont là depuis très longtemps
qu'est-ce qu'elle coûte ces femmes là à
tout point de vue au point de vue des
dépenses qu'on fait pour elle
il faut les nourrir il faut les soigner
il faut que le médecin passe
[Musique]
si elle était chez elle il y a longtemps
qu'elle ne sera plus en vie livret A
elle-même 160 rien sans chauffage sans
nourriture
elles sont là il faut s'en occuper
jusqu'à la fin tant qu'il y a de la vie
il faut s'en occuper
24 ans d'hospitalisation
coup 30 millions d'anciens francs
ou 300 000 de nos francs actuels
[Musique]